hello everyone and welcome today i
realistically think i'm probably going
to cry in the next hour i'm just going
to put that out there okay
we've addressed it from the top we're
about to play the new pokemon snap this
is a game where
for like my entire games media career
where anyone asked me
oh alana what game i'm too blown out
hang on turn my mic
down a little bit um what game would you
like to see have a sequel
it's pokemon snap and now it's out so
we're gonna be playing the first hour
i literally just finished downloading it
as the stream started which i will cut
that off so
anyone who watches the vod doesn't have
to sit here and watch it finish
downloading
um i almost don't want to do it because
i'm so excited about it um it's not that
i think this game is necessarily going
to be good
uh but i do think it's going to hit me
right in the nostalgia
obviously as someone who was born in 93
i grew up in the 90s
um i feel like pokemon was at its peak
in 2000
um just culturally it's such a big deal
and i love pokemon snap so
i'm really excited about this
[Applause]
um we're also as always raising money
for evil gamers for anyone who would
like to donate the link should be in the
description if i put it in
it is um which is an organization that
raises money
for disabled gamers where it's 16 855
which is very close to seventeen
thousand trying to raise 50 000
uh pretty much all my streams go towards
charity so we're here to have a good
time
experience pokemon and raise money
variable gamers
oh even the sounds are happening is the
is the mix okay
tell me if i need to make the anything
louder or quieter it looks like my
microphone's really loud but it might be
fine i don't know
okay
it's gotta be this one but she if i had
brown hair
am i doing it
it's probably i think i'm gonna go this
[Music]
one
cool tights look at you
oh look at a plat very nice
oh my god make him a little bit louder i
can do that
here you go let me know how that is
[Music]
do i get to walk around this area so
i've intentionally not watched much
gameplay
i watched both nintendo directs um but
now that i don't work in games media i
avoid
spoiling things for myself as much as
possible which is so nice
intentionally try not to know too much
about it
welcome to the laboratory of ecology and
natural scientists or lens for short
look at the little eevee oh my god
oh am i cutting off the text for you
guys i am let's move me
up here i also just panned my camera
weirdly do that
and then move all this around
it's a thing i never know what to do
with when streaming is
uh where's the text gonna be in this
video game versus this
hello mate you're gonna waddle over damn
it and i hate it when it's not perfectly
lined up but it's probably not gonna
happen i should just let it go
a lot uh just let it go you're trying to
play the video game that's gonna make
you cry
that one this one needs to move
yeah excuse me
uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh about there
is that good and about there oh i'd line
that up perfectly
okay let's do it
[Applause]
gotta take voyeuristic picks like it's
uh like it's dead rising
when they go good fantastic
also congrats on being a mod now scott
it's a huge day for you
dad my dad's name is vince what have you
been up to
okay i don't know that i need all this
context but
that's cool me anyway okay
why don't we step into the lab and get
settled okay
not the most settling place i wouldn't
have thought
there's a difference for what gravel do
i have a delay is that what you're
saying
oh you're saying between the things that
i've lined up
so i prefer not to know i did my best
the lenten region is absolutely teeming
with pokemon
photographing those pokemon helps us
learn more about them and their
ecosystem
and that's exactly what you're here to
do at night you might even get to see
glowing pokemon
that's cool
okay
you can use them to communicate all
right
keep in touch and analyze data on the
fly it also have a sort of id badge view
here so take
this is pretty high tech stuff you got
here
same bro that's how i feel about this
too
you don't speak for me video game
that's though it's alana what do you
think
i'm only gonna stream the first hour
anyway
um on here
well okay i'm using a pro controller
okay so i can't move the camera
don't you tell me why don't you try
moving the camera i should have just let
us speak
cool it a try
oh why didn't it take am i just supposed
to be moving you can point the camera up
and down
and even spin all the way around sweet
you can use motion controls
okay this is an excessive tutorial but
it's okay alana it is
sort of a children's game
it'll be important cool focus
is a little far away you tell me you got
zooms damn what is this high-tech [ __ ]
yeah you look nice and big now pikachu
that's what she said
[Music]
i disagree the rule of thirds is
actually more important in photography
but
go off queen
right okay cool you can also adjust them
cool okay tim gettys he's also playing
pokemon snap
okay let me take pictures of the pokemon
did i miss one in one of them my bad
first of all
okay cool
oh this is cool it's nicely organized
well obviously it's the big boy one even
though i actually like that first
picture better
very pixelated very pixelated it's
actually atrocious oh boy
can you do that john you can post your
photos to social media that's what i
hope people do with this i hope we get a
lot of like really fun
that's the thing that like a new pokemon
snap coming out right now is for all the
cesspool garbage that the internet
provides
uh i do feel like things like this like
photo mode
sharing stuff i'm probably going to
really enjoy seeing
yeah it's a bad picture actually so how
we you get me one stall
is that bad
i don't fundamentally disagree
so maybe i should have given him the
other one
all right okay just take good pictures
is what you're telling me i think
and that you really want them to be
center frame
thank you
oh it doesn't look that pixelated here
for some reason
sweet
how was it it's pretty chill thank you
all right okay yes please i would really
like to go on an adventure i'm very
excited about the adventure thank you
by the way the neo one
here's the thing okay
see it makes us use energy hot spots
scattered throughout the lentil region
what he was saying didn't really make
sense in any case but uh i'm excited
let's go let's go let's go let's go this
camera is sick dude
this is tight
[Music]
i'm very excited so take pictures of
pokemon
okay i'm looking forward to it
[Music]
so oh but i should wait i could get you
right now we can take photos pretty
quick out here huh
hello small friends oh my gosh i should
have got that one i think i [ __ ] that
up
i want i want you i want the dodrio
get over here big [ __ ]
okay hang on if i i was gonna say if i
zoom out i could probably get loads of
them
but you do have to focus on one
interesting okay okay go keep moving
along you know
how this video game works things pop out
of nowhere when you least expect them
the camera's just very slow hello you
little cutie
oh oh oh i missed it
see they're gonna tell me that's a bad
picture i disagree that's cute as [ __ ]
this is making me so much more anxious
than it did when i was a kid i'm like
but what if i'm missing stuff that's
behind me
what if what if
see and i'm like what is where where are
things gonna i don't know yet
it's like i can't play through it more
than once ella you're also very cute
hello
versus us
i don't know why i feel like i'm so
rushed
i don't well i don't have gyro on so
um i'm not gonna do that and i also i
don't like it so
oh magikarp man my boy
be my favorite gyarados is actually my
favorite pokemon
throws people off guard pretty often but
uh it's true
y'all need to get out of the way okay
i'm not trying to kill
a [ __ ] taylor out here
look how cute you are oh my
i still think this is a cuter picture
than if it were to be facing me but i
know that this stupid
hipster professor is gonna disagree oh
down on the d-pad to look behind thank
you
that's super helpful it gave me a
million tutorials very simple things but
didn't tell me that
wait do i have a limited number of shots
you're right i have 37 left that's even
more stressful
i want this magikarp though come on mate
also what's up hello hello
i just want this hot magikarp content
man
that's not very good we can do better
than that
jump you stupid [ __ ]
he's not gonna jump he's not gonna jump
it's okay all he knows how to do is
splash
we're we're already aware of that it's
what he does i was so close to getting a
sweet action shot right there hey turn
around
fam turn around pavilion turn around
face me [ __ ]
i did not expect to feel as anxious as i
do i'm just gonna
lay that out that is the
the thing that's really getting me is
that i'm nervous and i'm not sure why
i'm so nervous
oh cool what's going on over here
also like have i used too many shots who
knows
oh well that was just an awesome
bird but it's fine
i know the flops indeed brian this is uh
i oh okay well i could do way more i
really upset some pokemon fans by saying
that i thought the graphics looked
terrible
um they were like this is like the best
looking game that they've had it was
like yeah but
i still think it looks bad i did have
the kit where i could print my pokemon
picks yes
which is so cool oh you can increase
camera speed in the options thank you
that is good to know i mean they did say
that and i
rudely ignored it um but i think i
probably should it is really slow
oh microphone functionality would have
been awesome jacob that's a really good
point
did you daniel that's comforting i don't
know why i just felt so nervous
um okay see this part's gonna be fun for
me because i love doing this with
regular photography it's like picking
the best photo that you got of a certain
like that's a good picture i actually
think this one's the best one though
pavilion
we could try that because there's two in
it
just that one huh
that's super cute
that's a boring picture but it does the
job you know see i think that's the
cutest picture
but he's gonna tell me it's that one but
look at how cute that is
if i'm reading that the right way hang
on is it giving me the stars ahead no i
don't think it is
i like that one and that's good too i'm
gonna go with that one because there's
three of them they look like they're
hanging out being mates
i did take a lot of magic pictures
yes sax m13 i don't disagree that the
um art direction is really nice um
like i'm definitely with them on that
but like it's just
the edges are just so rough uh that yeah
when i
when we had the first reveal trailer
even though i was very excited about it
um i said that i thought graphics were
bad and i had so many comments with
people being like the stupid [ __ ] ever
played pokemon
it's like why we really really shook you
okay i'm not positive that i did that
correctly because i think it may have
been telling me the scores but i picked
the pictures i liked the most so
let's see what happens shelly
very nice yeah we're gonna go with the
new one
let's try and get like a 5 000 or
something this i mean this is cute as
[ __ ] dude
look at it you gonna tell me it's not
close enough
okay all right
jerk
the cutest thing i've ever seen 10 out
of 10 gold star
perfection oh i did get two stars there
okay i should pay more attention to this
rating system
it was two gold stars i guess you need
three to get a gold sorry two silver
i like the sound sound design is
nice
i knew he'd like that one is it called
stuff
[Music]
it wasn't very good but that [ __ ] was
far away i don't know what you want me
to do
that was also a gold star i'm confused
about the ranking system
discovery nice work
yeah magikarp content
work
we'll figure it out the stars don't work
how you think numerically they're for
rarity of pose color is the quality and
that's only given up scoring so oh
interesting
huh james
i've only seen that tampon ad once
on uh twitch and i didn't know they were
using it for twitch so whenever they
give me an ad for my own
i'm in the ad for my own stream i think
it's actually pretty neat
it's cool
a new discovery okay for anyone here to
know i did an ad for
tampax very cool with talking about lady
gamers
being comfortable addressing needs
um okay anyway
i should have been more inclusive with
that language people have periods period
having people
um all right i don't know if i did good
all i know is that i was very stressed
yes
after your research trips you can choose
photos to save your album which is in
your space in the lab you can also
choose
resnap to make some changes to photos
voice
i don't feel the need to do that right
now but wait i can only save a certain
amount of them
oh okay we'll save that
because it's super cute is there an
easier way to do this what does resnap
do
oh oh
interesting
i don't feel like i want to [ __ ] with
this yet but that's good to know that
this is an option
oh it's very slow um
all of these sliders i feel should move
just a little bit faster
so i would have loved to see ar
integration jacob um mike asks how do i
feel about the camera compared to the
first one so far
um i mean i've played that first game a
number of times um
it i mean we've got more options clearly
um but i don't really
i don't know yet entirely how i feel
about it
i'm gonna save that because it's cute
okay they give them their own
little headlines that's cute too um
we'll just save a few of them you know i
would say the ones that i like that i
knew that this stupid
see i think that's the cutest [ __ ]
thing i've ever seen but i knew he
wouldn't like it
adorable yes good
a lot of these are just called where is
it going this one's just a question mark
pretty common behavior
oh no what do you behave your question
mark
you don't sass me captions
how much storage do i have i should
check that
i could share the ones i have i see so
it doesn't actually
really require this is only for ones i
would want to share on social media is
what you're saying
which means that i don't care so much
but
we can figure it out as we go you know i
can always jump in and address this
later
let's do that and then
i don't know no i didn't want to say
that um okay how do i get out of here
then
i think that i've done it
right do i need to
do anything differently that's correct
we're gonna press the plus button
am i going to leave
i think i did that right i hope i did
that right if not
none of those pictures were that
gradient it's fine
they really are hyping up these
nighttime shoots
anyway okay
more pictures let's go
what
yeah dude i don't want to hang out with
you [ __ ] nerds
i'm out here trying to take pictures of
pokemon
do i have anything to throw or anything
yet i know that they did add some new
mechanics there i just don't have any of
them yet
you're right pretty common behavior does
you've got this most things
uh thoughts so far i don't have a ton so
far um
i feel like i'm still just in a tutorial
so we'll see
okay that makes sense it's so weird that
they feel like they need to specify that
okay
i did okay
that's neat some exploration
oh my god thank you so much amarost
thank you i appreciate that yeah i will
take um
donations from super chat for any of
these charity streams in a month
it has to be a month away to add to the
um
uh ablegamers uh goal so thank you i
really appreciate that thank you so much
all right so now i can press at x
to do a noise
look at us we've got a map oh my gosh
is this the same place that i was or
yeah that's the only place i can go
right now
let's go to park day let's do it
[Music]
this is the same place it is it sure is
but now i can see what scanning does
sup punks hey all right well we're gonna
take less photos in general
i should have got him when he was
looking at me i [ __ ] it up i already
[ __ ] it up
pay attention to me you look shook
it is making him react but he's not
looking at me
anybody
i would like to throw an apple at you
please
if they with the oh
i [ __ ] missed you again i forgot
about it um
okay hang on that will take it it's not
good but we'll take it
[Music]
i don't know mate did a pokemon do that
nothing yet so that's a thing that i it
just
said it didn't know what it was last
time a crystal bloom that grows on
florio
island you little pesky cute thing that
keeps evading my [ __ ] shots man
do you think this is what all wildlife
photographers are like
stupid ass pokemon get in my frame you
punk
hey these are not i'm not doing a good
job
oh action yeah
i take it back i'm doing a great job
that was also good i liked that one okay
who else have i missed anyone
it seems like not all of them respond to
this
hello my good sir he didn't like the
picture i took of you
which i thought was [ __ ] ridiculous
ah yeah
good you too okay i can't move the
camera fast enough
yes thank you
this is huge for me
they do not react all right
fine i don't know what i'm doing with
that okay i just want this [ __ ]
magikop to do something
sick
he won't though there's something for me
to scan is that what you're telling me
oh
oh oh no nope i didn't see you before
that was actually very helpful thank you
sensei and thank you sulu
uh can relate strongly can relate
um okay
what about you this intimidate this dude
like he's looking at me with the like
you came to the wrong neighborhood
[ __ ] type eyes look how [ __ ]
upset he is
like i'm sorry i didn't mean to i wasn't
trying to start [ __ ]
oh i do also um oh no technically i
don't have mine
okay could you turn around
please excuse me
is this what being paparazzi is like
you [ __ ] suck bro you're you suck
you're the worst you're rude you're in
kit
i'm just trying to get good marks okay
this is better than i had what i had
before
this is real [ __ ] though
[Music]
cannot believe the audacity ridiculous
um i still don't feel like i got you
know some of them were better
but
i'm not really gotten the hang of it yet
i do want to go in the settings and
change my sensitivity because
it is slow
um okay
who am i who's pronouns am i wrong about
what
um this is great so we're gonna take
that
these are all the same really that's
fine we don't really need to change that
terrible that's probably the best one
well thank you jared yeah the gyarados
ruled
so good that's sick but which one is he
gonna like more
this one i think maybe i'm not really
sure
jacob if somebody could uh edit it and
turn it into a fatal frame
that'd be sweet i love those games
we'll take it because we don't have
anything else
that okay let's go
yes oh i guess maybe it doesn't matter
if i double up on them so i just should
have
is what it's saying
i agree mike it seems like what made the
first one good is also here yeah
um
oh this is gonna be way better except
for the lack of other pokemon what
why does that look so shiny is that
silver or is that like a platinum
i don't know i'll figure it out
nice work
to switch between stars
if you've not got one of the x number of
stars category it counts as a new photo
okay
i'll figure this out we'll get there
nice work
i knew that one was good that was it
it's the only photo i have it's not
great but it's the only one i have
thank you i'll i will take the bronze
single star
i don't imagine there's a downside to
submitting everything i probably should
have i think
hey anytime no worries mate
i'm not going to save any i need to not
get too attached it's too early my
photos are all
probably garbage right now
i do want to go into the settings and
change the sensitivity though so i
should do that
however it is that i do that anyway
exciting here's the thing
speaking of
cool
what a wonderful picture classic my own
dad
cool yeah that's what i'm saying chase i
really like the music
what up wheezy that's elise
um settings okay
we could turn them on just to see what
happens i don't generally like them
though
yep camera speed
see how that goes regular no
frame guide zoom mode hold
toggle and find it hold final all this
oh no we'll keep it don't display
um that seems good we can play with that
again if we need to
let's go
spooky you [ __ ] around and hang out in
the park at night time
let's go i'ma see
[Music]
some glowy [ __ ]
[Music]
turn around scroll bunny you coward
face me cute
um this camera still needs to be way
faster
y'all are much closer is somebody
snoring
oh my very cute
okay nobody over here
i think i can get a good picture of them
though i think we can get
oh hey school bunny
[Music]
that is like probably the kind of
picture he's gonna want you know what
i'm saying
birds
ah oh i really had no concept of what
that was
okay that wasn't a great picture either
but
excellent tang growth
hello macro
oh what is it oh what is it is it gonna
be this
something is glowy
well we already knew that
stupid anybody hanging out around here
no okay oh hello
hello big cuties
this one is facing the front
that's actually a pretty nice picture i
like it
is going to be gyarados now hello
look how glowy you look
nothing okay did one of you move or
something someone i'm hearing
this you are like basically a stalker
dude do i need to report you
you need to [ __ ] chill out you are
really on my deck oh my god is that the
scale
is that really how big a pigeon is
i don't feel like they're that big i
disagree with you video game
i think you are wrong but maybe it is i
who is wrong
okay hello little macros you look like
witches and it's cute
who was just i still am very anxious is
what i'm gonna say
i'm still really anxious about this um
g'day rahul
no sorry mate i'm not playing card or
fifa um
we're on real gamer hours out here
cute very cute oh my god
okay who is it that's making the noise
ah oh i ruined it [ __ ]
[Music]
okay i have to take a really long flight
soon
you stupid [ __ ] dick
turn around son of a [ __ ] i swear this
is what being paparazzi is like
like when they were harassing britney
spears on the streets
they were just real upset when she
wouldn't face them okay what is it what
do you want me to look at what is it
what is it what is it what is it
is it that no that's
my own ting man what is it
it's over this way oh
i don't care stupid crystal bloom
i don't know what way a combi is facing
forwards but i'm pretty sure it's
not this way
what is it damn it you can't tease me
like that dude
ah
i never said that i would be polite to
the animals okay
i feel like even when i was a kid i was
probably out here calling things [ __ ]
dicks
okay i think i took some good ones here
that's what you think a picture of a
buffalont is
it's probably that one right
i think he's gonna like that one more
because it's action as much as i
disagree
cute
action as well even though it's cut off
it's very weird
choosing pictures that work best for
some idiot
ai rather than the ones that are
actually the most aesthetically pleasing
wait wait does that mean it was giving
me an indication of i'm not sure
i still haven't figured the stars out um
i'm gonna do that one because it's
really cute
i didn't know how big you were thus the
pictures are really bad
well see i like that picture the best
he's gonna like that picture the best
stupid pizza
okay let's show the professor let's do
it let's do it let's do it
yeah pokemon uh 700 is uh [ __ ] dick they
really you know when people talk about
pokemon getting less creative with their
ideas i believe that's what they're
referring to
so do i still dj ryan question out of
nowhere um
no because of the pandemic but i'm sure
i will start again when places are
allowing djs again
but no
i will never stop being mean to
children's game spirit how dare you
it's my brand
thank you
i think he's gonna like this one
not as much as i thought okay never mind
i don't understand
you as a human
just keeps the one that has the the most
points so yeah i guess you should double
up on them
cool
not great i thought it would work this
is a terrible picture
i bet he gives it 5000 points he didn't
okay we are lying on that one
this is a great picture except that it's
too far to the right
come at me bro it's platinum but not
multiple cells
this one's going to be three
i still don't know what it means to be
clear i saw that pikachu printer jacob i
really like it i sort of want it but i'm
actually not sure if it's for sale
uh very cabbage you said just landed in
here how's the game so far i'm having
fun so far i will say
it's like very tutorial heavy right now
and where
probably haven't actually played for an
hour maybe like 40 minutes or so we
played for so far
um so yeah i don't i don't really know
yet
it's very it's fun and pleasant
definitely but i would like
more ways to interact with the pokemon
which i imagine i am just yet to unlock
loot boxes
cool this is strange i didn't expect any
of that
is this this game about
microtransactions
okay what i would be pleased to hear is
that i get to go to a new place
if i'm being completely honest with you
mate that's what i would be pleased to
hear
uh yeah jared there's basically this
this um pokemon printer
it's like an insta printer thing sort of
similar to how they did it back in the
day i'm not exactly sure how it works
i've just seen it and it looks awesome
but i don't know where you can get it
or even how really oh that's right
energy spike
here's the thing hmm
don't think so i'd prefer to go to
another area
if i'm being honest you guys but if i
need to go back to the park
i'll come back to the park
back to the park it is oh i can just do
that okay great cool let's go
uh how's the new job with santa monica
it's wonderful best place i've ever
worked i absolutely love it
thank you
well that's definitely where the reading
was coming from
do you see i don't know mate just you
right now
that's also a big boy i have him as a
shiny and pokemon go though
this i would have flipped out as a kid
seeing that
not like it's not pretty now but get his
picture
turn around [ __ ] look at him she's
running away
oh my gosh yeah i look back at it i love
it when she looked back at it
there's something wrong with me oh
so this is probably the end of this
level it's probably you get like a big
pokemon at the end of each level
oh [ __ ] oh
this is kind of what pokemon go
feels like in the real world like one of
the best things about the timing of when
i went to japan
was that it was during the maltress
events so
you'd be at like this japanese shrine uh
with loads of people the lobbies would
always be full trying to catch a
maltress and then like showing each
other the pictures they took of the
maltress and it was like this rushed
thing of being like this
gonna be here for so long we gotta get
the moltres man it was uh very
very fun to have that game be as popular
as it was when when in japan because we
would also
find people who couldn't even speak
english uh and trade
uh american pokemon with them and they'd
always be like do you have this pokemon
and just kind of point at their app
because they realized we were playing it
it was really cool it was a very very
fun experience
oh this is pretty i would like to go
here in the real world please
well now he looks like he's beheaded
oh look at you you have so much trouble
running with them little baby legs
you look back at it hey cutie
oh i realize the pokemon do all have
their genders listed
and i've just i have just been ignoring
that um okay cool
i think that i took some beautiful
pictures today so
hopefully we can go
to a new place now with what i'm hoping
for
also a friendly writer everyone we are
really close now i should read out the
donations um we're raising money for
ablegamers
been uh doing it for a few months now
trying to hit fifty thousand dollars
um thank you to the underscore b you
said new pokemon snap use nostalgia it's
super effective
thank you and thank you to anonymous for
the 176 dollars and chris for 20 dollars
and i think 100 as well uh
that was from the live stream thank you
guys we're like like really really
really really close to seventeen
thousand
i think we can make that happen is all
i'm saying but uh thank you all so much
it's a course that i think is very
important helps people with all kinds of
disabilities
play video games the link is in the
description if you would like to donate
here we go hang on i can let you do it
there you go okay
oh is is this you suggesting that i
picked that one that is a good picture
i don't disagree i don't disagree
look at the little persona intro he got
there
i still don't know what the points mean
4 700 is not that much
it's not it's not that much mid-range
picks usually not more
points it's not about having one good
pick from the end
oh interesting what i think that i'll do
um because of the way that it
like the way streams work in the other
game if you take good on a pick then
sometimes
correct yeah or it makes pokemon do
different things um
i will probably when not on stream just
try to pay more attention right now i'm
just trying to kind of show the game
really
um still shaded
is it a new place dude come on
she look back at it
this one is really pretty i think that's
the one that i used
look how cute it is i shouldn't be doing
this i know that
very soon i'm not going to care about
any of this but look how good these
pictures are dude
come on i think this is adorable
i look forward to memes coming out of
this absolutely
um okay cool
very exciting um sorry you nerds didn't
get to go and you had to be stuck in the
lab
the [ __ ] docks you are i'm out there
in the real world
it was very cute it was a very cute
pokemon
i have to go to sleep
i'm just i don't want to sleep i want to
take pictures of pokemon
this is a lot more narrative than i
would have expected but i'm alright with
it here's the thing
it's pacing they gotta pace out the
unreal structure somehow right
[Music]
okay i guess
do i get to take more pictures or do i
have to hang out
absolute nuts because that's not what i
signed up for
excellent well then let's make it
official
well that's pretty cute actually i'll
take it
classic me whenever somebody gives me
something i just kind of go
yep that's how we do it
all right
damn you unless you're giving me more
tools
i keep feeling like these are loot boxes
and it's very weird
means i'm allowed to go new location you
know collections
all right thank you
ma'am i think you'll find it's an apple
okay
this is an apple i know that you think
that it's
oh sorry that's you know what uh
i spoke too soon and i just corrected
her really rudely oh we had 17 000.
let me just get away from the shame i
just brought to my name by insulting
this woman by seeing
acting like she i really mansplained is
what happened there
um thank you to ex sensei anonymous and
connor
we have now hit seventeen thousand
dollars and thirty
no seventeen thousand and thirty four
dollars is gonna say 34 cents
raised for evil gamers which is an
organization
um that helps people with disabilities
play video games
uh because it requires expensive
specialized equipment a lot of the time
and ablegamers provides people that
equipment free of charge
uh it's it's awesome so thank you all so
much we still have a long way to go
several months um more of every single
one of my streams that isn't
in some way affiliate with someone else
for some reason we'll be going towards
ablegamers uh what happens when i hit my
goal
probably just a big celebration that's
about it
all right um i should put in some
milestones i've never done that for any
charity streams before i should start
doing them probably
i just think because i do it so
frequently that that that would be tough
to keep up with
you know i don't know okay this not
apple and definitely a fluff fruit
we'll throw with this pikachu there you
go boy oh
very cute
sweet great i'm trying to hit it
come on bud yeah
that was really cute
it's adorable
thank you luda uh the shoes on my most
recent instagram post
are really somewhere i guess i don't
have them out right now
um they are jordan one highs
uh league of legends zoom
if you search league of legends
like jordan so you'll find them
it's a long name otherwise but yeah they
came out to
last year's worlds i think
len talk we've got everything
okay you guys are gonna talk to me more
i don't really want that
but um you know if that's where we're at
in our relationship then that's fine i
guess
well that's got to be the skull bunny
doesn't it
what is this
that's really cute um okay
i would like to oh when they yawn
okay interesting i would like to be able
to get them to show themselves
i don't know how
that's a cool way to do that i like it
um okay
i think i still only have the same pock
though
come on you've got to give me a new
place to go
the fluff fruit i guess will help um
we'll do the park at night
[Music]
punk you little punk get appled
didn't really do anything oh cute
i'm sorry little buddy
uh okay
hello mate i'm really just out here
harassing these
sleepy boys huh come on
oh i didn't know that you flew that's a
much better picture of that
pidgeot oh again damn it
okay i'm cool with it now where's this
idiot that flies up here and i miss
every time
all right canopy come on
it's soon i think there's so many of you
were you here last time
no maybe not maybe i'm wrong
what do you do if i give you apple you
just get
stuck stoked he's psyched he's
it's the best thing he's ever seen in
his life oh i'm sorry micro
um all right anybody
anybody what is the what is the why is
there so much noise i don't feel like i
need to
look at you again you're fine i don't
you want me to is that
what's happening do i need to scan it
every time i disagree
oh oh what's that i missed that the
pencil comes out of there
ah regret okay good to know
excuse me mates
trying to make you yawn wake up [ __ ]
do you think that this is how nintendo
intended for people to play this
just profusely swearing at it
hello no again more
open your stupid mouth
come on man i'm trying to make you yawn
somehow
nothing useless
okay um skull bunny
is gonna do something at some point too
i don't know where he went
punks get out of here
why not
come on dude you're on yes yes we got it
success again successfully harassing
pokemon
just wake everybody up oh he's sleepy
oh my okay um
no i shouldn't have zoomed in i still
[ __ ] it alani [ __ ] it up turn around
turn around turn around turn around turn
around you want you were coward
yes
okay that's a way better picture
um all right well what's happened here
oh that's just the
exit
hey bud i like your cute face
can i surely i'm gonna miss this there's
no way
um the
i didn't catch the skull bunny burning
anything
stupid punk um
i'm curious if there are like
combinations to get things to evolve and
stuff
it really is like dragging us in
slowly here
which i'm alright with it's probably
longer than i expect the first game is
really short so
it's clearly this one
it's so cute you want to get the yawn
right that's what you are after
i love it okay let's go oh
yeah i know i'm fine
i do not live in australia i live in la
but
you're not wrong australia does have
some dangerous animals um i think it's
exaggerated a little
but i'm not gonna pretend it's perfect
you know
the spiders are large
i thought that was like a perfect
picture what are you what up
yeah a new discovery
not as good as i would have hoped i also
thought that was a very cute picture
but i got the yawn that's what you were
after oh that was so many stars
wow okay all right
well i have to don't i it's always got
to be the same
course because i don't have any more
courses professor
mirror
[Applause]
stressed about who all the people were
it's fine you can't do it
um yeah jared i have huntsman spiders
around where i'm from
but they're everywhere in australia but
they're also professor
venomous so um they're just big
and terrifying but yes i would see like
maybe two a year or so i am very scared
of spiders but they're not really a
problem
who's this [ __ ] chad look at him
no he's a chad he's a professional chad
he's a professional pickup artist for
thank sure are we going somewhere else
an old travel companion nice what'd you
guys get up to
okay are you trying to steal my photos
to sell them
wow i don't trust this todd fella
don't trust him at all
conflict you're the dorkiest kid i've
ever seen in my life
okay now wow look at this drama in my
pokemon snap
okay i'm alright with it
they really are going hard on the
narrative you gotta respect it you gotta
respect it okay
now that you're all here we can get
started
listen up team i'm going to give you a
breakdown
that's not as an exciting thing to say
as you think it is
i am excited about that being a new
location though
okay
wait this is our first destination
okay i'm excited
so i think uh i will wrap up the stream
after we
um do the second location i need to edit
the podcast but i figured i would just
do that as a twitch stream and then if i
have more time
before i go hang out with some friends
tonight which i probably won't
we'll see um because we're all
vaccinated i'm going to see
autumn and charlotte and fiona a very
good rt group of very awesome people
whom i love
um i get to meet that puppy i'm very
excited about that too
uh then i will play more pokemon snap
otherwise i'll just do it probably
throughout the week
but let's do this first location let's
go
i'm stoked dude that's where my
charizard's gonna be
it's gonna be up in that corner that's
where it's gonna be
okay cool i feel like starting during
the day makes more sense doesn't it
let's go woohoo
it's happening
todd's who you played in the first game
i've played that game so many times and
i didn't know that
there you go i never paid attention oh i
forgot i turned gyro one
sup you little cuties look at you oh god
oh god oh god
okay am i did i just go back to the park
again
or is this actually a different location
it does look
it does look different but similar
layout
i confused myself excuse me mate could
you uh could you look over here please
bud
i'm suspicious
hello yeah oh that's the best we've
gotten of our dodgerio the whole time
i did select the same level okay let's
uh let's just get out of that one
i've not been there in daytime in so
long that i wondered if it would be
different
fiona said she's planning on getting
wasted
i wasn't prepared for that
um all right i selected the park
again by accident it's fine we're moving
on yes
that dojo photo the [ __ ] it did look
different though i don't feel like the
dojo was sitting there before does it
evolve as you play through the levels
that's
an interesting approach to that um
return to camp pick the actual new level
this time
then i'm very excited uh devin i'm gonna
be honest it's a good mix i'm very
excited to see
autumn and charlotte from inside gaming
obviously i loved working with the two
of them they are wonderful humans
also very excited to hearn okay so
that's
the park it was in a literally a
different island
that makes more sense because i have to
unlock the nighttime
let's go
i make a lot of mistakes when i'm
streaming because i'm talking to people
it it does happen
with extreme frequency it's fine
this does look more different we feel
good about it okay
thanks man
this is like the level in the first one
you see like the poliwhile
look at me
are we about to get wrecked by that
branch no okay cool
roll on through then
oh my gosh that was cute
hello how are you doing my friend
damn it come back come back okay it
wants me to scan something around here
it's over here it's oh oh my oh i don't
love that i'm not a huge fan of that
hello it's like oh my gosh oh hello
can you come to say hi slacking
oh my god i this keeps making me so
anxious about all the stuff that i'm
missing
it's okay alana the game is designed for
you to play through every level multiple
times
you need to chill the [ __ ] out it's okay
you're allowed to miss things right now
it's fine
the higher you'll level on a track the
more different it gets oh that's neat i
appreciate the effort that they put into
making this rough
cool it's a different color here i doubt
that photo of that arbok is bad
it's okay he maybe he ain't trying to
chill
hello my friend glad to see you in the
wild team rocket hasn't gotten you yet
that's cool
also that thing is huge can you imagine
how scared you'd be of seeing that in
real life
my god can you [ __ ] off dude you're a
bit of an attention seeker
oh that was cute that was a cute noise
you made hello question
big lump of
anybody anybody anybody
um yeah definitely getting the
impression already that this game is
going to be a lot longer than the
original one which um i think i already
said this but was for sure one of my
criticisms of the first game it's it's
real short
which is like fine for when i was a kid
aren't you pretty oh good stretch big
stretch
you're back again [ __ ] what now
yeah good splash i'm gonna do that again
oh he just
something else to scan
ancient ruins that seems like a thing we
should explore
okay okay okay okay
who's that who was that no just a rock i
thought it was maybe a rye horn
ah
i keep feeling bad for bugging them when
they're sleeping if somebody were
throwing not apples at me while i was
trying to sleep
i'd be shook
turn into a gyarados you punk i'm just
trying to encourage you
oh hello you're going to look back at it
too
no
hello hello hello hello hello you're
very pretty
um oh look at these cuties look at them
being cute i should have got a [ __ ]
picture of that damn it
he's such a big target why do i keep
missing
buddy hello okay it's fine
honestly bro i have so many pictures of
you you can just go away
okay are you trying to get these for you
for your gram are you farming content
is that what's happening here
i just want to give a quack sayer a hug
that's just something that i'd really
like to do
in my life anybody hanging out back here
it's a terrible picture but we've got 19
left so why not
a cave
somebody in there anybody anybody
anybody anybody anybody
come on surely somebody's in there
don't play me damn it
uh i'm really liking this so far
this is fun um it is it is
it is pretty unique in the way that it
gets you hooked on like oh i'll get that
next time oh i'll see what that does
next time
um i definitely again feel anxious
playing it
which is really weird like horror games
don't make me feel this anxious
um
[Music]
i like that one that's good
terrible but whatever that was ah
almost good
fine
let's do see it this is definitely an
instagram model trying to get hers you
know and it's fine
all right i'm cool with it but just
don't act like that's not what you're
trying to do
probably that one
i think that's a nice picture this one i
want to stretch
big cat do a stretch okay it's gotta be
this one that's so cute and then these
flowers for some reason
um all right let's roll let's do it
that's not a good picture i actually
thought that i had gotten more of a palm
but
i think this one's a good picture and if
you disagree you are wrong sir
and i will cancel you accordingly you're
wrong
jerk well that's
this isn't good it's um you don't need
to validate me on this one
it's true i didn't cry i did expect to
and i think that i would if i found a
charizard or something
but right now no tears involved we have
not cried
i think this game still does have the
potential to make me cry but right now i
feel like i'm just so much in a tutorial
yeah it wasn't a good picture either
it's fun
this is a good picture this is a good
picture
[ __ ] this is also
a pretty good picture but i understand
that it's flawed because he's too far to
the right
[ __ ] yeah this this stupid professor
doesn't know what he's talking about
this is a big cat doing a big stretch
this is the kind of content the internet
likes you [ __ ]
thank you foxhound i really liked
fraternal i was very into it um
this headset is a windows surface
headset um i love it it's got really
good noise cancelling you like push it
forward or push it back
you push it back i think it noise
cancels if you push it forward it
actually
creates volume so if someone's far away
from you you can hear more
um it's pretty cool that was a good
score on that one
i think that's very cool um i'm gonna
leave it there though
i'm into it this game is fun the vibes
are good i like it it's actually a fun
game to stream
um even though i'm previously swearing
at them the whole time but that's
what else did you expect okay all right
uh i am going to
edit the podcast which i have to do over
on
twitch and uh hopefully i can actually
get it done
but there will hopefully be more pokemon
snap streams which will also be over on
twitch
i'm just going to keep trying to do
these like first hours of gameplay on
youtube to give anyone who's interested
in the game my first impressions live
basically
i feel like that's good youtube content
where it's just like regular streams go
over on twitch
um but that's pretty much it thank you
all for joining me this is very exciting
thank you for helping me hit seventeen
thousand dollars
for ablegamers and yeah i'm just gonna
probably go make myself and get some
water rather and then i will be on
twitch in like maybe like five minutes
or so so
yeah thank you all for joining if you
want to join me over there we'll see you
there if not
enjoy pokemon snap thank you for joining
me